welcome to 2000 and no my god 10 2009 I
think he will agree was very very fun
nothing like a good economic downturn
but 2010 promises to be even more fun
than the collapse of the economy and I'm
here today to tell you one reason why
but before I do why don't we talk about
my terrible gesticulation I mean look at
this finger
it isn't even vaguely in shot show your
fingers charlie
it's important to show you fingers
otherwise people won't know what you
mean
two of my favorite video buggers in the
entire world Hank and John Green from
the vlogbrothers puff fight these lovely
chaps have decided to do something very
interesting with their year they are
putting on a massive video conference
called VidCon VidCon oh my bacon butty
is here thank you
I'm at my dad's house at the moment so I
had to veto my entire family from
entering this room apart from my dad
bringing in a bacon butty for me the
quad the idea of VidCon is basically to
bring youtubers together to gather them
as is per normal but instead of just
gathering youtubers it's going to be
bringing them together to go to loads of
YouTube related talks YouTube related
music performances loads of other
different things which haven't all been
finalized yet but are very very cool but
why am I telling you this it is because
Hank and John have been nice enough to
invite me to go and talk at VidCon and
to place music I'm going to be bringing
my ukulele along and performing some of
my hits they've asked me to stand on
stage for 45 minutes and talk to a crowd
of people which and they've asked me to
set up a charity booth which will
involve people coming up to me pain to
put their fingers in my mouth and me
biting them and then saying ouch Charlie
and if you don't understand that then
don't worry it's not important I can
bite people's fingers you know I haven't
got much experience what I don't expect
it's gonna be very hard and I've had a
bit of practice at playing music for
people as well but standing on stage for
45 minutes and talking there is a reason
that you see so many jump cuts in these
video blogs because if I didn't include
them all my videos would all my videos
would look like that and that is a very
entertaining but I can't do jump cuts on
stage which is why I'm making this video
oh I finally get to the point I am just
one person but you are not
one person you were lots of people and
you lots of people can help me when Hank
and John told me that I was going to be
doing a 45-minute long talk for VidCon
they also told me that the title of my
talk is going to be is Charlie so cool
like question mark so what I thought
would be cool is if we took this
45-minute session of me being on stage
and used it to have a massive Q&A
session in which we try and answer the
question is Charlie so cool like two
things you're gonna need one
are you a person and two do you have any
question for me so that you would like
me to answer on stage at VidCon I've
been told that on stage at this thing
I'm going to have a big screen so
hopefully what I'll be able to do is
show loads of video responses from
people and answer questions like that
and answer questions from comments as
well and show those on the stage and
also answer questions from people in the
audience but do bear in mind that I'm
hopefully looking to answer more
intellectually stimulating questions I'm
less likely to answer your question if
you're asking me what my favorite color
is or what my favorite Jonas brother is
but I'm more likely to answer your
question if you're looking for my
opinion on Schopenhauer's interpretation
of love or say whether or I prefer
pirates / ninjas if you're looking for
more information about how you can
attend VidCon click on this link here oh
yes thanks for your time and ask me some
questions otherwise I'm going to look
like an idiot on stage with nothing to
say you've just had the almost
imponderable joy of watching Charlie is
so cool like which makes you like cool